[Music]
ideally somewhere for like this one in
Mexico
thousands of kidnaps for ransom take
place around the world each year ruining
lives wrecking families and generating
billions of dollars for criminals but
the profile of kidnap victims in certain
places is changing and kidnapping has
also created a growing industry one
which saves the lives of victims I was
in a dirt road just like this in Mexico
I was going to go spearfishing and
that's when the guys pulled up in front
of me with the truck slammed on their
brakes and jumped out with a gun
and pulled me into their truck and
kidnapped me they wanted a certain
amount they weren't gonna take lower
and if it was lower I was dead
in 2012 Shayne Anderson moved to Mexico
where he was kidnapped the country is a
hotspot for the crime the scariest
moment was when they had me go stay on
the edge of steep hill where there was
garbage at the bottom and he lifted the
gun up right at me and he just said I'm
sorry it's too late we have to kill you
kidnap for ransom works like a market
the victim is the commodity the
kidnapper and the family the traders
both parties have to come to an
agreement to exchange the goods I think
I've kidnapped for ransom as the
trickiest trader in the world you are in
a trading situation with somebody you
have no reason to trust it mostly occurs
in areas where there are civil wars and
where governments are in conflict with
cartels terrorists and other armed
groups a large number of multinational
companies and NGOs operating kidnapping
hotspots and so employers take out
kidnap for ransom insurance to protect
their employees what you get is a
promise to reimburse around some with it
comes the services are for crisis
response company that will help you make
that trade succeed more than 75 percent
of fortune 500 companies have K&R
insurance policies and they work around
98% of insured criminal kidnapping
victims are safely retrieved the people
who are insured should not know that
they are insured and how much they are
insured for they might give this
information to their kidnapper and
therefore change their kidnappers
expectation of where the hostage
negotiation is likely to settle paying
out large ransoms can make
hostage-taking
a more lucrative and attractive crime so
rather than a multinational company
front the bill the families of the
victims have to come up with what they
can to begin the negotiations this
controls the ransom demand from the
outset and regulates a transaction once
the ransom is paid the family is
reimbursed
[Music]
K&R insurance comes with a crisis
response team it can include a
negotiator I believe I have been
involved in 121 cases negotiators can
bring the initial ransom demand down by
10% and limit violence towards the
victim you have to build trust with the
bad guys through time in credibility and
mourning it was instrumental for me
having a hostage negotiator because they
have local knowledge you can have all
the money in the world but if you don't
have that knowledge I'm not going to
survive when they finally decided to let
me free after the last ransom payment we
caught a bust and went to a bigger town
where I could catch a taxi
it wasn't until I knocked on the door of
my friend's house where I knew my wife
was that they knew that I had survived
[Music]
foreign kidnaps like Shane's however
only make up a small proportion of
kidnap victims worldwide but today in
Mexico the profile of kidnap victims has
changed in recent years when kidnapping
began the victims were mostly well known
and wealthy kidnappings were targeted it
wasn't a coincident they had information
they knew where they live the cars
bank accounts I mean they did their
homework previously but today kidnapping
is a crime which mostly affects local
middle class people taken out of the
blue and for less money a quick fix for
criminals these victims were most likely
not have K&R insurance
[Music]
in Mexico kidnapping has come from the
millionaires to the rich to the
middle-class to people with really
modest resources we started having
random cases wrong place wrong time this
is partly because criminal gangs in
Mexico have fragmented so there is more
competition for the drug trade and
kidnapping people is another way to make
money but another worrying reason is
that the Mexican government has been
largely unsuccessful in reducing
kidnapping only an estimated 1 percent
of all kidnappers are captured and
brought to justice it's easy to get away
with so criminals have no reason to stop
doing it